hello linkedin
we are live i'm joined by faroot today
excited to have you on farooqkun
obviously you're joining me in
dubai we're just going to have a bit of
an open honest conversation
for the next sort of 30 or so minutes we
want to answer your questions i know
farooq's keen to help
so if you have any questions whatsoever
drop them in the comments
but let's start by for those that may
not know who you are freak if you could
introduce yourself
and then we'll uh get into it
great thank you um so my name is farooq
mohammed as hisham mentioned
i'm the md of digital gurus we set that
business up
in 2008 just after just before the
recession
um about two weeks before the recession
and we grew that and sold to the rethink
group in 2016
and uh subsequently i
grew the business internally for the
rethink group over the last
four years and that's what i've been
doing as the md in there now i sit on
the board of the group as well
awesome amazing and i have to obviously
share
what you're doing in dubai so
i'm in dubai uh i started an mba
a year ago and as part of that you do a
week
in a different city learning about
different businesses and different
industries
so my week was in the middle east so
i've been spending it
meeting lots of different businesses
like airlines and
pharmaceuticals and all sorts of
different businesses and business
leaders
and uh that's why i'm here i wish it was
just
um doing whatever else else is doing in
dubai and having a great time
actually
why have you decided to do the mba i
decided to the nba because
i reached a point where i was like okay
i sort of
um i've got comfortable in the pattern
of what i
do is in okay so if we do x we get y and
we get z
and i didn't know what i didn't know
right so i wanted to expand that push
myself a little bit more
meet people that were outside of the
recruitment bubble was a big thing and
so i decided to do it at that time and
and it actually has ticks pretty much
all of those boxes i've met loads of
good people
i've pushed my learning on um i've
learned more about different businesses
and then
realized how you could apply those
lessons to recruitment
and also how businesses think both
small startups and large corporates and
how they think in terms of growth and
development and strategy and
how you apply that to talent and
recruitment really so it's been really
good
and really good always be learning
always be learning man i'm like always
having a book in my hand or something
like i just like to read i like to learn
and i think it's important for everyone
because otherwise you just become stale
you just because you don't know what you
don't know right so always be learning
i love that so i wanted to start
as i said for anyone that's joining us
if you want to ask freak any questions
hit them in the comments but i wanted to
start by giving you a bit of a scenario
and give you a bit of an opportunity to
sort of share some things that you've
learned on your journey so the scenario
is
farook starts a recruitment business in
january 2021
right you've seen the back of 2020
you've had enough right i'm i'm
taking it back into control i'm going to
start my own business and at the same
time another person starts a recruitment
business in jan 2021
you both have aspirations to build it
scale it
sell that recruitment business and
they get to 30 people over a time period
you get to x amount of head count and
you've successfully sold and exited that
recruitment business
what did you do differently to that
person okay
um the first thing that you've done
differently to that person is that
you've
researched and analyzed the sectors and
geographies that you wanted to go into
so what i mean by that you might have
gone right one person might go i'll go
into digital because that's what i know
and
that's what i've been doing one person
might go actually i'm going to go
into quantum computing or artificial
intelligence i've heard that that's
growing
so you research the sectors that you
think are going to grow
over the next however long the period
that we're talking about let's say it's
a five year period
which are sectors that are going to grow
in those sort of areas you've done your
research you know that you can
get a certain amount of roles short
medium and long term and it's only going
to grow
so what i mean by that is that you look
at an industry and you go this industry
is going to grow 10
year on year so next five years so for
example fintech you were like right this
industry is going to grow 10
year on year the next five years i'm
going to that and the other person might
have gone actually i'm gonna stick to
what i've already got and that industry
might be only growing up one percent a
year so you've chosen a better industry
you've done your research the second
thing that you've done
is that you've um put your business
aligned to certain metrics so everyone
has certain metrics that they work
towards that fee to the bigger goal
so you'll be like okay cool we know that
our metric might be
the amount of first interviews that
we've got that translate into second
interviews that translate into deals and
everyone is aware
of their own personal metrics because
you're going to have different metrics
of different people
that's going to be the second thing you
run your whole business on data
and finally you're going to be um
non-emotive when it comes to decision
making
which is really really easy to say and
listen i've been plenty your motive in
decision making in the past
but the more that you can be
how can i put this uh i don't think
there's a nice way to put this but the
more that you can be ruthless about
decision making
in order to drive the business forward
the better your business is going to be
uh short medium long term
and then obviously alongside that you've
got the best talent you've got the best
advisors
and all of that feeds in of itself and
what happens in that journey
and i'm going off piece a little bit but
what happens in that journey is that
success breeds noise it breeds
people looking in and going well what's
happening over there and that
that it becomes easier to attract
good talent because people are looking
here all the time anyway
so it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
so the key things that those businesses
have to do is pick your right market
first of all it's really that's the most
important thing
secondly make sure that you understand
how you operationally want your business
to be running
so okay we these are the key metrics
that we want
and finally you're executing on that
plan and reviewing that plan all the
time and amending it as you go along as
well
those are the three key things that i'd
say that would really put those two
businesses separate
over the next five years just a quick
point on one of those
can you be too niche
um
like neat like do you have to niche blah
blah which are completely
can you be too niche in my opinion i'm
not gonna be uh
saying that yeah you can actually in my
opinion yes you can
um because you can go into a sector
let's say for example
a sector that i know let's say you go
into digital and you pick
creative within creative you've got
different sectors as well so you go
right i'm only going to specialize in
copywriters
and there's only so much of that
marketplace that's going to grow so one
of the points that i made there was like
how
how much is that market going to grow
over the next five years year on years
five percent 10 growth rate 15 if you
niche into a market that's so small
it won't grow if a market's not growing
there's only so much you yourself as a
business can grow
so i do believe that yeah you can be too
niche you've got to pick a sector
and then obviously you have niches
within that
within your organization
what's your sort of typical go-to place
to look what sort of core things do you
look at
for you to be to have confidence that a
market is going to grow
honestly not many not many and it's look
and i didn't i'm just giving you lessons
of what i've learned
of how to do things better and what i
would do differently now
not many do that at all but you can find
a lot of this information online right
so the first thing you do is like
you identify a couple of sectors you go
and have a look at how much of these
sectors actually growing
what the what the analyst saying that
get paid to do this stuff why they're
saying it's growing what's it
underpinned by when you've got that
self-confidence that you've got the
right area
then you go and pull the building blocks
alongside that to go actually
and i've done the research i'm going to
go and speak some candidates
oh how many job offers do you get or who
the growth markets
how many companies call you up you start
to understand the
the area that you're in right so i'll
give you an example on this
let's say for example you choose an area
that's growing 50 year on year
but every recruiters every single
recruiter is in that field so then you
work out
how much of a percentage am i going to
get you know what's the likelihood and
be realistic on that
and you work out what that's going to be
in terms of sales then you work
you see another sector that's growing
ten percent year on year there's
two recruiters in that sector then you
work out
similar percentage what am i going to
get in sales and you work out which is
going to be more and it's always going
to be the one where there's less
less competition so that research that
bit of detail
that you put in beforehand is is
huge it's huge in giving you an edge um
and it's something that actually is
sorry i was just going to say
strategically
that's something that we don't really do
because we're all trained as salespeople
we don't really think
strategically uh sometimes
i just think like this especially this
time of the year
i think it's the perfect opportunity i
know i
i know i always spend time so at the end
of the year i always spend time to just
sort of reflect on me as a person really
not just professionally
and go back through sort of my journal
and these things but like i think this
i wish i did more of this for sure in
terms of actually look at my recruitment
desk in 2020
and be like right like 2019 i got these
amount of
jobs in this particular job title now
i've got this you know what i mean i
think it's also something that
people should be looking at for their
own individual desks right and actually
recognize well actually
maybe there's more senior positions here
maybe i actually
have a focus that's more focused for me
do you get what i mean i i just think
it's a good practice again for yourself
as a request
listen what you said in terms of let's
take it down to granule level as a
recruiter
right if i'm sat on a recruitment desk
because we were talking at the macro
level well let's take it to granular i'm
a recruiter i'm reviewing my desk for
next year
i want to go from 150 to 200. what's the
typical recruiter going to do
he's going to say i'm going to build
more okay
cool how you know how you actually going
to get from 150 to 2.
you've got to review your marketplace so
you go okay i did it in let's say for
example you work in healthcare so
doctors and nurses for example
okay i'm going to work with doctors and
nurses i've got these amount of
customers
i need to understand how much of those
customers going to spend then i need to
understand also
is my sector still growing is there any
legislation coming in that's going to
impact me
what impact is that going to have on my
desk let's say for example they ban
using recruitment agencies for hospitals
right and they just blanket ban it and i
know there was
some stuff around that before that's
going to have a huge impact on your desk
okay once you're aware of that then you
can put together a plan to go
okay what other markets am i going to
need to do or am i going to pivot into
in order to deliver 200. so you can
start to put together
something you're absolutely right you
should be doing this at granular level
it's super useful and it's definitely
something that's going to
make people more successful because it's
just a piece of analysis that
is invaluable we tend to do the job all
the time
we'll go in we'll graft every single day
we put our calls in and whatnot
a little bit of planning beforehand will
help us do the job
so much better because it just gives us
a guide and that plan needs to be
reviewed monthly
and quarterly and every six monthly and
yearly
just so that's why you can't get your
way through not always working in the
business and work on the business
and i think that's something that how
you should be sort of treating your desk
for sure
um had a question come through from
anthony
fazon i know that this is something that
you can't see his name but i can see it
on
my screen anthony gargan so basically if
you read that i think
you gave some really interesting
insights on this on the podcast
around the sort of metrics that you
looked at but it seems like just for the
people that listen back to this the
question is from a poem recruitment
perspective
which things would you make sure are 100
in place when deciding the right time to
begin
hiring is are there any specific metrics
you'd look at when trying to grow head
count
from say one to five so i guess what i'm
saying there is
i want to grow what where should i do
that's going to give me confidence or
what should i be looking at yeah there's
a couple of things and it's the sort of
things that we've been touching upon is
like
what is the market saying is the market
growing so you've got to be confident
enough to go
okay yeah the market's growing so that's
the first thing the second thing that
you look at in yourself is like how many
perm jobs have we had come in how have
we filled
how many have we not failed okay if we
had another person would that help us
fill more
would it not help us fit more how are
you going to put that person into your
structure so for example
um let's say you had 10 jobs a month
come in and you were filling one or two
of them
you felt that if you had another person
come in you might feel three or four
but what you're bringing that person in
for you bring him as a delivery person
if you are you bring him in as another
recruiter if you bring in another
recruiter
then maybe that 10 jobs is going to
become 15 to 18 jobs
and you might be filling three or four
you might want to actually think
should i be bringing another recruiter
or a delivery person because i've
already got 10.
so i'm filling two that'll help me feel
full
you'll actually end up making more money
doing that sort of stuff so
those are sort of metrics that i'd be
looking at as what what's coming in
what's the market saying in terms of
growth what am i not filling it's really
really important to know what you're not
feeling
and what you expect to feel if that
person comes in
i'd always used to look at a really
simple metric i'd be like okay
what's the percentage fill rate that
we've got with our staff
and then once we started hitting a
certain metric of okay this percentage
fill rate
that automatically the flip side of that
was our failure rate
once we hit a certain failure rate and
the market was still growing i
could see that all the analysis was
saying the market's growing
the amount of jobs out there wasn't
going quiet you can look on linkedin to
compare month or month
just really simple stuff if we were
having at the highest
failure rate i used to start thinking
about hiring people and then obviously
the infrastructure internally that you
put in to determine their success or
failure
yeah a lot i think that whole job to
fill ratio um
and i think that's that was a that's
what i really took from your
the the podcast and i guess it's worth
thinking
um faz what about thinking if i was in
anthony's shoes i'm definitely thinking
cash flow i'm thinking all i've got to
worry about right now is i know what my
sort of overheads are
i guess would you maybe even say to this
person have a bit of a runway i don't
know how would you think about that in
terms of cash flow wise in terms of
yeah absolutely i i'd probably be
looking at um having at least three
months
worth of runway uh for this person you
know you've got to give them enough time
to become successful
and without you putting pressure on your
own business in your own pocket and
whatnot so
i'd be ideally looking that we've got
enough in the bank
for for at least three months most
businesses don't fail because they
um have a lack of uh work coming in
most of them fail because of cash flow
they're just not managing
the cash correctly so what you're
hearing is actually the collection of
cash
is actually the so i don't know there
might be i mean you've heard their
stories right recruitment businesses
have like a million pounds worth of
invoices
left outstanding right or even less than
like a substantial amount
and i think as a when you're a recruiter
day to day i definitely was this person
you're like yeah 25 grand on the board
smashed it this month
but you have no even idea of like we
haven't even got that money yet as a
business you know what i mean
yeah i mean look totally valid point and
that's part of cash flow is that cash
collection
so you've got to you've got to be able
to get that money in the money
if you're a smaller business like the
one that we were just discussing a
minute ago
where you're looking to grow from one to
five that person's gonna be doing
everything the recruitment
the hiring the cleaning up the cash
collection everything and it takes away
from doing the main core job
so cash flow is absolutely critical
you've got to build that in
into your day-to-day so for that person
another metric that they'd also be
looking at depending on their size is
how much time is that other per the new
person coming in gonna free for me
because let's say for example that one
person was doing
cash collection invoicing out talking to
customers
setting up all the job boards setting
out adverts getting in another person
would mean
actually that one new person they've got
can focus more on new business
which would mean that they're getting
more jobs in which also means that they
should be filling more jobs
leaving the first person to focus in on
the stuff that they're focusing in on
in the first place i'd say that um i
don't know how
true this is but i'd be interesting to
find this out i'd say that those
businesses that start with two or three
people
tend to have more success because they
have that infrastructure or that support
mechanism internally to go
you do cash collection you do invoicing
out or accounts or whatever and i'll
focus in on sales
so it just allows them to spread that
out so i think it if you are thinking
about hiring put that into the metrics
as well think about that yeah well um
so i know i i always ask people on the
podcast like sort of
important attributes as a actual
recruitment consultant but i wanted to
ask you like what do you think are the
most
important attributes for an actual
successful recruitment business owner do
you think
i think both as a business owner as and
as a recruiter the successful attribute
so
um i'm not and we touched upon this in
the
podcast i think it's really important
that people have
a willingness a hunger a passion and
desire because you can't give them
that right and we sort of touched upon
that but i also think now more and more
that they've got to be
something that we were talking about
earlier willing to learn
you've got to learn new skill sets
especially in recruitment most
recruitment
business owners start as recruiters
we're taught a diff
completely different skill set so you've
got to be willing to learn this new
skill set
if you're just a you know on on the
hands the most important people the ones
that do the job if you're a recruiter
what's the most important skill set that
you've got to have it's that tenacity
that will to win
that drive to go i'm gonna come in i'm
gonna work really really hard
i'm gonna work out what i need to do and
i'm gonna execute on it
but you need to have a willingness to
learn there as well right you've got to
be able to do the research
choose your market to choose your
sectors to be able to approach customers
and all of that goes hand in hand so i
think it's really similar
similar skill sets for both yeah
and how i wanted to get your thoughts on
was like because i'm sure you've been
thinking about this
a lot and yeah with what you're learning
and everything else but like how are you
like looking at the recruitment industry
landscape going into next year like how
are you
feeling about it what what sort of comes
up for you
i was reading a couple of reports and
it's
forecasted to to bounce back and that's
not going to be a surprise to many
people
are seeing the talent sector in terms of
growth of hiring is still forecast
growing at six percent a year uh europe
is still significantly growing the us is
growing even faster
and there's other international regions
like india and china growing faster as
well
so i think that it's actually going to
be um
fairly aggressive in in certain markets
but then
when you analyze that it is eight
percent growth or six percent growth
which
depending on which market you're in
there's certain sectors that are driving
that
there are other sectors for example
retail right now if you if you asked
and or hospitalities really suffered i
think it's difficult for me at this
stage to
to go how quickly will that bounce back
do i think it will bounce back i
certainly think that hospitality will
bounce back
i don't think people are going to get
tired of going to restaurants or bars
and things like that
and is it going to be different to what
it was probably
so i'd be looking at things like okay i
think the sectors are going to
bounce back but which sectors did really
really well during covid
i'd probably be looking to to be going
into those sort of sectors as growth
i think there's going to be significant
growth in healthcare and social care
because of um the under well what was
exposed as under investment in those
areas over the last year i think there's
going to be significant investment
in cloud and infrastructure with more
and more people working from home
with the um flow of money into those
sort of areas i think there's going to
be significant growth
in public sector recruitment as well i
think there's going to be more
state spending over the next four to
five years
so i think that if you are in certain
sectors the ones that i've just touched
upon i think
there's going to be significant growth
and by public spending sending it
spending i mean like
infrastructure spending so things like
roads hospitals schools
so i think if you're working in
engineering and
those sort of sectors that touch upon
infrastructure i think they're going to
grow significantly too
and how like how what do you think could
be the biggest change
actually in the recruitment industry do
you think like how obviously you're
talking about the sectors and these
things but like
what change do you think because i think
like i think it's a really interesting
question to ask yourself like what
the industry or business owners in this
industry have learned this year like
what
what's going to stick with them going
into next year right like i don't know
what what do you think gonna be some of
the biggest changes that you can see
i think um in terms of changes is that
it what's been proven is that
the best companies that have invested in
their it infrastructure are going to
have an edge
i think that that is going to be a
differentiator when it comes to hiring
now
for the future i think in terms of
what's going to make a significant
impact in this area i think the use of
data
and analytics and the analysis of that
data
to drive decision-making in small and
medium-sized organizations
companies that gear themselves up to
measure stuff
and can measure stuff historically are
going to do well
and i think the technology is going to
continue to have a significant impact
in the in the talent sector i think
there's going to be more and more
companies engaging with candidates
directly
but i also suspect that more and more
companies will outsource
their recruitment to um recruitment
providers
and the reason being it's not fixed
costs so if you're a
cfo now in a large corporate you don't
want to have
a massive internal hiring team because
you don't know when you're going to hire
or which
areas you're going to hire in and how
you're going to hire so you'd probably
go actually
i'd much rather go to a recruitment
agency where we go with a flexible
contract
we can gear it up or down and i haven't
got a fixed cost and the paye and all
the
benefits that you paid to staff and all
of that so i think that there's going to
be significant
growth of those sectors as well so those
are the sort of themes i think
um of change we will see in recruitment
over the next three to five years
would you start a recruitment business
in this market
yeah like the comments honestly i've
seen a huge influx from the lens that i
see the industry and i've had so many
conversations with people that started
their own recruitment business six
within the last six months i i think
that this is
the perfect time to start
[Laughter]
why that is why it makes sense to some
people
because um you're gonna have massive
growth investment over the next three to
five years in the right areas
yoga it's a perfect time when a lot of
your competitors i
every other recruitment agency have had
to slim down
they've had to readjust their spending
which means that they've got really
really good people which they wouldn't
got rid of
normally so there's more people that if
you can get hold of
that that's a unique time to to do it
and you can undercut
your competitors you can understand
price right now price and quality
matters
so if you can if you can offer a
brilliant solution
and price it well you're going to give
yourself a bit of an edge
and it'd be interesting to get your
thoughts on what you've seen in this
sort of rethink group but
in the last a couple of weeks i've had
and obviously i know it depends on
sector but like i've had
numerous conversations with either
recruiters or recruitment business
owners who have gone
heisham i've just had my best month
or heisham in the last sort of couple of
months we've had the record month
frequent month record month
have you seen that or how did like and
why is that i just find that so
interesting
listen i have seen that in certain
sectors and certainly within the rethink
group without touching
too much detail within that and and it's
been driven by
being in the right space and if you're
in the right space look it's still not
done
just because you're in the right space
you're not going to make tons of money
you've got to be good at what you do
you've got to be brilliant at servicing
your customers and your candidates
you've got to have a really strong brand
you've got to be ethical at all times
because people see through that and they
want to keep coming back for more
you still got to do the basics really
really well and i think oh
the overarching bit of that isn't you're
in the right space
you know i i'd be i'd be interested to
see i'm not ruling out but i'd be
interested to see which hospitality
recruiters have had
record months in the last you know i
definitely haven't
the only one that i spoke to hadn't
podcasted
and i don't think that's a coincidence i
think that a big part of the drivers
have been
right right space strategically in the
right space smart enough to see the
future coming
and secondly they were brilliant at what
they do absolutely yeah
we can't get away from it it's like what
i've had a lot of people have said
either like
obviously the vaccine gave a lot of
people confidence for sure
that the three people said that and then
also a lot of people sort of
felt um told me that like the companies
that they were
sort of originally who had always been
working with at the beginning of this
year were like
complete breaks on but and then in the
last three to six months
it's actually a real understanding of
okay well we're def in this for the long
run
like we need we need to push on and we
need to
carry on we can't just be stale or
listen that's totally reasonable isn't
it from a business point of view that
you're like well actually we can't just
wonder what's going to happen we put the
brakes on let's sort of start to think
about the next
two three four five years but as a if
you're in the space where they weren't
even thinking about that right there's
certain spaces where they're like
we've got more work coming through
because of kovid because more people are
working from home and we've got more
deliveries going on
we've got more people buying because
they're a bit bored or certain products
being bought
those areas they would have actually
grown significantly i wouldn't be
surprised in those sectors that people
were absolutely clean enough
now like those companies that um
specialize in cloud and infrastructure
talent there is no doubt in my mind that
they were cleaning up over their last
six years
yeah i've got a mate in that sector
actually i went for dinner with him last
night and they've been cleaning up
listen not a surprise but but they've
been in there
six years they've been doing it for over
six years is that exactly you see
they saw the future come in and it just
it
absolutely boomed when a black swan
event happened
and they were able to take advantage so
they deserve the credit for being in the
right space at the right time
let's just really quickly faz before we
finish talk about and
if anyone else has any questions please
let us know in the comments before we
finish but um
obviously we've spoken a lot about
starting a business all these types of
things but how do you
from what i can see there's there's
going to be an even more competition
from a recruitment business owner
perspective on getting the best people
right or keeping their best people right
if that's
there may even be more opportunity now
people starting their own recruitment
business or whatever but like
what what's been your advice to people
that you've connected with
or people the advice you give to people
on retaining
their talent like how do you think about
that i think in terms of what i've
noticed actually let me just start with
what i've noticed is that
people have actually really looked after
their top people recently
i've definitely seen that there's not a
lot of people moving and the ones that
are available being snapped up and had
multiple offices offers so i think
that's a that's saying a lot about the
sector at the moment that people are
really clued up to
to seeing their talent and in terms of
uh what could people do to attract
talent is that is that what you were
sort of asking or were you
sorry i guess i wanted to just get your
thoughts on like because you always hear
people
talk about yeah i want to grow headcount
blah blah blah but
not loads of people will talk about the
actual retention of their best people
right so i guess
how would you be thinking about keeping
your best hands
we just yeah you picked up on that well
in terms of keeping your best talent
you've got to communicate
all the time what's the plan what we're
doing
what's the ambitions people like to work
for a business that's ambitious that's
growing that's moving forward
so you've got to be able to communicate
that what does it mean for them
always make it about the staff because
ultimately they're the most important
people they're the ones that are doing
the job
you know i'm not i don't sign up to this
thing that the people in a boardroom or
and the directors or whatnot and i'm
talking on my own behalf here not anyone
else's behalf but
the most important people are the ones
that do the job
all directors for me work for them so
how do you entertain those people you
communicate that message
you communicate what the plan is how
we're going to get through when you
treat people
with respect at all times and obviously
you've got to be competitive
you've got to be competitive in packages
without um
putting yourself in such a disadvantaged
position where the company's suffering
so you've got to get all of those
balance things right but for me you've
got to be
totally transparent in what you're
trying to achieve and getting everyone
aligned to that goal and that mission
yeah and i think if you haven't been
that this year
people are going to want to know how
you've been
that i hear that all the time like
that's even just from uh not just
um interviewing recruiters through
recruitment and business perspective but
when recruiters i'm speaking to them
about their market and what they're
hearing in conversations they're going
hey faz yes you know that client that
you told me about how they how they
dealt with covered what they've done
they want to know about how they've how
transparent they have been what they've
done how they've communicated and
if you haven't sort of emphasized that
people are going to remember that right
the one thing that i've learned over the
years is the root of
every mess up is communication
and the route to fix it is communication
communication
is absolutely the heart of it and the
more you can communicate with people the
more you can empathize with them the
more you can empathize with them the
more you understand exactly where each
side's coming from and you can
find common ground yeah i love that
right so to finish this
i want to ask you like your what would
be your
i guess if i'm a recruiter or if sort of
you're more leaning towards recruitment
business owner it's fine but
what would be your like three best tips
for me to start
next year in the right way i'll have the
best vocabulary research
right research that's the first thing
the second thing
is um plan which uh kpis are most
important to you
and the final thing is talk to your
candidates
go and talk to them find out from their
point of view how they feel the market
is where the growth areas who's hiring
what do they like about recruiters what
do they dislike and make sure that your
service offering
is unique enough to go and apply it to
them i i know there's somebody
out there right now that has done those
things and i think is going to be
successful off the back of them
yeah freak thank you so much pleasure